OK, I've been a bit tricky in the last
couple of exercises because when I organized all of
the chromosomes from biggest to smallest, I left out
a pair. I left out the very last pair, because
as you noticed there is something very unique about
them. They don't match in size in the pair
the way all the other chromosomes do. In fact,
they're so different, and they're important for a very different
reason, that they're not numbered like the
other chromosomes. It's the 23rd pair. But each
chromosome, because it's unique from the other,
has its own name. We call the bigger
chromosome the x chromosome, and the smaller
chromosome the y chromosome. Together we call these
chromosomes the sex chromosomes. All of the
rest of the chromosomes are call autosomes and
the reason we make a distinct is because
the sex chromosomes X and Y determine the sex
of an individual. What we mean by sex
is whether or not the individual has male reproductive
organs or female reproductive organs. And there's a
very interesting story, as to why the Y chromosome
is so much smaller than the X chromosome
and they don't match. The story is awesomely amazing,
but it's really outside the scope of our course,
so if you're interested you should go search for more
about it on your own. The key point here
is that the y chromosome triggers male development. So if
you have a y chromosome, you're most likely going
to develop as a male. Without a y chromosome, ultimately,
the individual will develop as a female. Now I
want you to tell me. Using this set of chromosomes
that you see right here. If this was
an individual's genome, what sex would most likely
develop from this set of chromosomes? Would you
expect to get a male or a female?